calendar
it's my intention to go through the
bills
in order with the lowest number first
and go through
the bills
and I accept them accept emotion and and
then we can uh have a discussion and
hopefully get through as much as we
possibly can today I'd love it if we
could get through all the bills that we
currently have pending and I hopefully
we'll be able to do that today
the
unless there are any other business that
we need to address now then
[Music]
uh I will start our discussion this
the chair you have to take attendance
first don't you yes I am sorry I'm too
anxious to get going
I don't blame you
and read the prepared script really yeah
as chair of the house Judiciary
Committee I find it due to the state of
emergency
declared by the governor and as a result
of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to the Judiciary
Committee executive session on pending
legislation may be held please note that
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
Zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a the right
to know of anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 that's
leg.state.nh.us in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
a lot uh we also have a staff member who
will also be attending the meeting
that's Jennifer for our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting will
be done by roll call vote
we'll begin the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also State whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
I'll begin by saying this is Nick Gordon
I am at the Legislative Office Building
in room 206-208 with other committee
members
and Mr clerk will you take the role do
complain
uh president here in the room
I'm getting there it's uh it's
representative Sylvia in Belmont Home
Alone
good morning
foreign
[Music]
representative sober is absent today and
a substitute has been provided well
right and the committee was done it but
the committee was provided but notice
that he would be absent today and that
representative Stephen Smith would be a
[Music]
thank you professions in room 2068
representative Gray
here with my wife in Hudson uh you are
breaking up a lot it is hard to hear you
I wasn't here and just got here my
internet out went out one second before
I sat down but I'm back and I'm here
alone in Temple
representative Tosh
hi I'm here at my home in Merrimack
alone
good morning I'm here at my home in
Belmont in the office alone but I do
have children in the house
representative Smith
I'm here in Durham in a house uh
functioning on a generator because our
power's out and in another room in the
house is another member of the committee
hello
representative Burge
uh good morning I am alone and I'm in
West Milan and we just got our
electricity back a few minutes ago
representative Horry
um I am oh actually I need myself
I am representative Oregon I'm here
alone at my home in Durham
representative De Lorenzo good morning
I'm alone in my home in New Market and
there's no one else in the room
looks like she dropped up
she's here but she's muted it looks like
there she is there she is oh there we go
representative Kenny
thank you uh good morning I am here in
Durham um I am actually at
representative Smith's house in a
different room so thank you for having
me representative Smith and uh yeah
thank you
representative Langley
I'm here in Manchester
um with my husband I'm having trouble
with my video
however but I am here
representative Macbeth
good morning representative Macbeth is
here in Portsmouth alone in her home
office thank you representative Paige
good morning I'm alone in Exeter home
office thanks
uh Simpson
good morning I'm here in Exeter alone
right now and my husband and Sons are in
the house and may come through at some
point later
representative Chase
good morning sorry about that I am here
home alone in Rollinsford
the attendance 21-0
noting that one person does have a
substitute
yes having
[Music]
having taken the role uh we'll begin our
session this morning we'll go through
the
the matters that we have pending today
in order and we'll begin with House Bill
82 an act relative to amending a
conservation easement between the state
and a landowner
yes representative representative Sylvia
I understand that representative Burch
has an amendment but I would move itl
um
I believe this involves a constitutional
interest
issue of contracts and I don't think we
can study our way out of that but I'd
move IPL with the chairman would accept
it thank you
there's a motion to uh to recommend
an expedient to legislate is that
by uh representative Alexander
and you want to address your emotion
representative sovia more than you
already have
great uh this is a very complex issue
and essentially when you boil it down
these
easements are contracts and and often
contracts with people who have passed
and
our our constitution our first article
second
um supports the
concept of contracts and even if this is
a simple study committee I think it's a
study committee with a dead end and I
believe that uh
that's a little bit too much to overcome
so um yeah so that's where I'm going
thank you
um I obviously opposed that motion and
should that motion not uh succeed I
would be moving an amendment that
narrows the uh scope of the study
committee uh to the particular statute
that's blocking a solution to this case
and to some other uh similar easements
all the uh it seems like most of the
parties agree that the situation with
some very old easements under a very
specific statute
um
is working in Injustice and I would hope
that this committee would take a stand
in favor of the little guy in favor of
the citizen in favor of the farmer as
opposed to uh government bureaucracies
and the like uh it's kind of a freedom
issue for my friends across the aisle
um and uh basically the idea of looking
at reforming a statute is what the
legislature does that is our business
and this study committee is supported by
the Attorney General's office the study
committee is supported by the uh the
Commissioner of
Agriculture Sean Jasper this uh the the
head of the charitable trust division
came and told us that he felt this
specific statute needed to be worked on
and uh I don't support too many study
committees but I'm even willing to to be
on the study committee uh as needs be so
I would urge this group to
um
not vote uh to close our ears to the
pleas of our small farmers and our
citizens uh reject the itl so another
chairman I would just say that we don't
really need a bill to do a study
committee we can an ad hoc committee can
be formed and it can be done we don't
need to formally create a study
committee for this if it's if it's that
important
thank you Mr chair um I
it's just like you humbly disagree with
the member from Belmont's uh
constitutional theory in fact if
anything uh
if anything regulating and enforcing
contracts is one of the most important
things to cover government government
does I did those have no jurisdictions
over contracts is
not something that I would I would agree
with and then anyway in this case um
if that if there is indeed a well first
of all we're only dealing there's only
also but if indeed there is a
constitutional impediment to doing
anything about these old easements which
were the emphasis for the bill
um
study committee can get together a few
times and I think a formal study
committee would have uh more stature uh
more uh you probably have probably have
a higher priority on the various experts
time so if indeed there is a
constitutional impediment to which I
don't believe a study committee is a
good way to uh to look in look into that
but I think
I think the study committee has a much
broader scope than that so I think it's
a
I think it's a perfectly uh I think it's
a perfectly I think it's a very useful
exercise and so I think we should go
forward with it thanks
[Music]
I realize I'm I'm a visitor here but I'm
looking at the underlying Bill and I'm
confused by the debate because I don't
see a study committee
it it I I think that if the Ito motion
is defeated representative Burge intends
to offer an amendment uh thank you
further Edward sure without the
yeah I I don't think we're the I don't
think the intention is to debate the
amendment I think it was offered by
representative birch as his potential
yes representative McLean uh yes thank
you Mr chair I agree with representative
rights I I do think there is some
inconsistency with some of the new
easements in the old Eagles so there's
an opportunity here if an amendment were
to be offered however I don't think we
need the committee
um I I would actually favor emotion of
retention and I think this is something
that we could do within uh the committee
ourselves so that's that's what I would
favor
so as an alternative to
as an alternative the itl you'd be
looking for
retention I've been looking for
retention as an alternative
um but that's not promotion on the floor
right now thank you and representative
rice did you have your hand up I did I
was that was what I was going to say was
why can't we just retain it and work on
it in the committee and rather than
and representative Birch uh if if that's
what happens I can certainly live with
that
and
representative Alexander uh thank you Mr
Terrible you do it for all my second
okay you're withdrawing your second
and would you withdraw your motion
yes multitasking um
I I will uh certainly uh with grow my
motion uh assuming uh I will not be
studying the retention I just don't
think I'm constitutional okay so uh
representative withdrawn as motion is
there somebody who wants to make a
motion to retain or make a motion to
retain so representative McLean makes a
motion to retain I'll second that
representative Chase
all right well whoops a couple of things
I wanted to say if we do decide to do it
internal study committee I would like to
be on that and I would make that second
motion if
so we have a we have a motion to retain
the bill
uh currently and is there any other
discussion
seeing none uh
if you obviously if you vote uh yes
you'll be voting in favor of retaining
the bill if you vote nobody be voting
against that and Mr clerk would you take
the role
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman uh retention uh
Hospital 82 representative McQueen yes
representative Sylvia
I know
um by the way representative McLean does
not have video going
but he's in the room
ah okay
that I can't tell so I I would just tell
you that if I turn mine on uh you would
be getting so much feedback and we've
all had that issue so I don't think
anybody in here has their microphones on
uh you said no a Grand River it's
representative Sylvia
I said no correct
uh the cork votes yes representative
Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes
representative green
yes
representative Kelly
it is
yeah that whole mute button thing is a
representative Tosh
yes
representative Marjorie Smith
representative Birch yes
representative Horrigan uh yes
representative Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny
yes
she said they were having problems early
with the internet so I wonder if it went
out
that'd be interesting representative
Macbeth
yes
representative page yes
Representatives uh Simpson yes
Mr chairman yes
yes I have to vote as 18 years two days
and one a representative Glenn if you're
here you can still have a chance to vote
18-2 and the bill will really retain the
committee
next bill to be addressed this house
bill B3
representative Birch if you want to make
a motion thank you I would
um
move OTP and also be moving a small
Amendment 0-3
uh 0369 h
uh
well he can address the amendment what
was the amendment number
[Music]
I second
if you want to address your motion go
ahead representative Birch yes as I
indicated uh at an earlier hearing the
amendment uh makes it clear that this
um
uh Bill
affects claims by or against a
government unit so we've covered it in
both directions basically whether the
government unit is a plaintiff or a
defendant
we would not have uh secrecy along the
lines of this bill so it's a small
Amendment but that's what it
has been suggestive and I think it's a
saying that are you ready to go
yeah we're voting on the amendment
questions
and then the 0369h you were thought
uh represented between
yes
representative Sylvia
[Applause]
presented three
yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Josh
yes
representative Marjorie Smith
representative Burge yes president of
Oregon yes
representative Lorenzo yes
representative Chase
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
welcome back representative thank you
representative page yes
representative Simpson
yes
that brings us to the
motion
as amended the private class is amended
culture
is there any other discussion on that
foreign
yes
and Ford quote yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes Representative
yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh yes
representative try here
yes
representative Marjorie Smith yes
representative yes
representative Morgan
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative Simpson
yes
Mr chairman yes
20 years one day
representative Morgan I have any
interest in doing the Minority Report
oh no that's okay you can put it on
consent too as far as I can think so uh
no I'm
so we are recommending not to pass as
amended at house level 83 and without
next next bill is House Bill 108 an act
relative to minutes and decisions and
and then representative McLean
[Applause]
awesome
motion made by McLean seconded by
representative wolfer and if you want to
address your motion
just quickly um I I think that this is a
minor burden
um we've heard testimony in the past of
uh a tendency to have sealed minutes
accumulate over time and there's really
nothing that uh goes back and provides a
review
um this is a minor burden where you
would go and as you decide to to seal
the minutes from a non-public session
and keep a list
um it'll just make it easier if you want
to go back and do some cleanup or some
periodic review of that
um to be able to do that so I think I
think it's a real game for transparency
ought to pass on high school 108
representative McLean yes
representative Sylvia yes
yes representative Alexander yes
representative rice yes
yes
representative Kelly
representative Tosh yes
representative
yes
uh representative Marjorie Smith yes
representative bird
yes
representative Morgan
representative diorenzo yes
yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Blankman yes
representing Macbeth yes
representative page
yes
representative Simpson
Mr chairman yes
there's no objection this will be placed
the next bill is House Bill 111 an act
establishing a positive action against
the state
individual rights
representative
second
seconded by
representative Simpson
it's going to be one of the pressure
Bones from representative
I think we've discussed it pretty
thoroughly I just appreciate that this
is a bipartisan effort and wanted to
acknowledge the work of Representative
leakis uh in assisting on this bill as
as well as the institute for justice
any other discussion
foreign
representative McLean yes
yes
at work quotes yes representative
Alexander now
representative green
yes
representative Kelly
representative Colossus yes
representative throttier
now
representative Marjorie Smith yes
representative Oregon uh yes
yes
represented Langley yes
yes representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
Mr chairman
yeah
uh does anybody have an objection if it
were to be placed on the consent
calendar
staff
I think I would like to make a motion if
I could to
obtain that bill
it provides I think that's seconded by
in England also segmented by
representative
I think this provides a real opportunity
for estate planning if we heard the
testimony that this is something that's
been adopted in a number of other states
through the other states and to provide
an effective estate planning tool for a
lot of people
their only asset enlightens their house
they might want to be able to transfer
without having to do complex estate
appointment
but but I discovered after we had the
hearing was that this has another impact
that's an impact of our registry of
deeds that's traditionally in the
registry of dates you either have a
grant or a grantee
in this particular case
you really don't have green tea until
The Grand Tour dies and this is going to
require the call of the bill seems
simple in terms of what it's going to do
between one person and another
it has some effect on government
operates and I think that that needs to
be studied addressed before we put this
into effect I'm just asked the committee
if they would be willing to retain the
foreign
Mr chair who seconded that
to retain House Bill 124 representative
McLean
yes
foreign yes representative Alexander yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
representative green yes
representative Josh
yes
here
representative Marjorie Smith yes
representative Burke yes
representative Oregon uh yes
representative Lorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes
representative Langley yes
yes
representative Paige yes
representative Simpson yes
german yes
nothing we will retain the bill
in committee
next bill is House Bill 133 and act
creating a cause of action for
censorship
beautiful
yes representative Sylvia
is there a second for that I'll second
that
representative you want to address your
motion
uh sure just briefly um this bill is
really pretty unworkable
um
essentially it would if it were able to
be applied it would
restrict New Hampshire companies and as
opposed to perhaps the offenders that
are
more desired to be affected so it just
representative Oregon
um thank you Mr chair well there's a uh
very fundamental First Amendment issue
and that the First Amendment
freedom to press also covers the right
not to use your press publish uh publish
that material you find objectionable and
also um
the business model of these social
networks is to provide
people with content which they want to
read so they can label Shadow banding
but that's pretty much you do is they
preference you distribute things a lot
of people want to see as opposed to
stuff that nobody wants to see and
that's um there's that are their
fundamental business models so if we
go with the shadow banding unfortunately
is part of it because and um
also I think the barrier to entry are
probably not quite as large as people
think to someone if a
um these platforms come and go so the
ones that there is so there's like a
free market
incentive to be like as inclusive as
possible so I
think this is a
and also of course this is a federal
issue anyways this is a bad bill so I
further discussion on House Bill 133
they have a motion pending for any
Clerk
the experience a legislate Hospital 124.
representative McLean yes
representative Sylvia yes
virtual GS Representative no no no wait
excuse me we've already done 124. this
is 133
yes representative Sylvia yes
yes
representative rice yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
representative green
yes
representative Kelly yes
president emergency yes
representative bird yes
representative
yes
representative Kenny
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
and expedient legislate who's concern
next bill is House Bill 135 act
requiring parties responsible for
pollution of a drinking water supply of
the financially responsible for certain
consequences of that pollution
representative McLean you have a motion
yeah I guess thank you Mr chair Mr chair
um I move off to pass and offer
and is there a second to that I would
second that Mr Chair
thank you Mr chair
um uh even though uh Blitz field is in
my district
um I was not an original co-sponsor on
this legislation I think what changed my
mind about this legislation is right
after the election I got a letter from
uh
basically stating that they were filing
a rape case with the puc for over 20
increase you know for the people in
Litchfield and it really made me realize
that although they had had no
involvement in bringing this to Bear
they were going to be bearing the
consequences of that for 10 20 30 years
and so I think that there is some Merit
to the legislation
um there were concerns in the original
legislation
um as discussed uh by Des really wanting
to clarify the nature of the hookup
preferring that the city water and that
the Standalone units be more a temporary
thing until we could go in that
direction and also fears that The
Five-Year compensation
would be a barrier to compliance so what
the amendment does it just basically
clarifies that we want to go forward
with the city hook up when possible and
it cuts to five years back to two and so
that's basically the fundamental content
so we're actually I think addressing the
amendment right now correct and another
see it
but then I guess we'll be voting on the
amendment as offered by
representative McLean that's Amendment
adoption of amendment 0473 to household
135 representative McLean yes
yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
represented me
yes
representative Kelly
I'm sorry
representative
yes
representative Marjorie Smith yes
representative Morgan
yes
serpenter Morgan
Oh I thought that was unmuted yes but
yes
representative deorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny
yes
representative Langley yes
representative McBeth yes
representative page
yes
representative Simpson yes
after the amendment
21-0 so now we are back to the
uh thank you Mr chairman
um
the amendment makes this just slightly
better but uh
I think the bill overall is is not very
well written
um I think it's
people kind of at the mercy of the
commissioner is stated so
um I don't think there's enough details
in the language that sets out all of the
uh
the uh remedies so I'm going to be
voting against the bill although you
know it's a great idea but I don't think
it really delivers what it
ought to like good water
thank you and McLean thank you Mr chair
um I I understand uh representative
Sylvia is concerned about the Des
commissioner but we did hear his
testimony that there is um arrival
appeal to the waste management Council
and then a further appeal available to
the New Hampshire Supreme Court so there
is in my opinion still the preservation
of due process with this building
foreign
[Music]
actual damage it this bill doesn't
require any actual damages it's all
prospective the potential penalties that
it will be paid are unlimited because of
the time frame from these states will
work out might be Unlimited
and the cost of compliance might be
are you thinking which building
no no this is not the medical honoring
though I'm speaking to the wrong
building Mr chair yes so I just I just
wanted to clarify that this is this is
this is a this is a very clear
circumscribed remedy this is just a lot
yes as I understand this bill
well it talks about consequences the
title not damages so the word
disappeared the text of the bills think
the idea of this bill is to uh
um it's enable is to make it a make it
harder is is to make it uh to encourage
uh all the parties to take competitive
action so the uh the person for the
polluters will have to take preventive
action and that might uh that should
save them save them money in the long
run and save the effective people uh of
the suffering because
um
if you filter the water supply or
otherwise mitigated and if you stop the
pollution then that uh that's a better
solution than just letting the pollution
go unabated and no preventive action and
then people uh
people have to suffer uh have to suffer
the damages and then go through the
whole court process so I think this is
uh this is good because it uh it makes
the problem but
prevents a big problem from becoming
huge so thanks yes I think this is a
preventative
these are discourages preventive
measures so that I think that makes it a
you know their discussion
if not Mr Clark the the motion is not to
okay
uh Hospital 135 uh box pass and
Amendment 4473
representative client
yes
Clark wants to know
representative Alexander now
representative Bryce no
Representative Steve Smith no
representative green
no
representative Kelly
oh
representative Josh
yes
representative
now
representative Birch yes
representative Oregon yes
representative diorenzo yes
representative Chase yes
representative Langley yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
yes
hey you've adopted the motion a
can someone repeat what the vote was I
couldn't understand him right it's
12 to 9. in in uh in favor of ought to
yes there will be is that going to be
okay the next bill is uh hasco 160 an
act relative to notice of rent increases
in certain residential rental property
[Music]
no Alexander representative Alexander
excuse me
and
you want to address you representative
certainly
um
while we don't call this rent control it
is rent control it's got to start
somewhere and uh the first place to
start is uh
dictating
terms of renewals of lease
so this is step one if we can go this
I think the system as we have it now is
well it's not exactly great it uh it
causes rinse to be higher this would
just increase that problem in when we
have affordable housing issued
uh these sorts of things do not help so
that's where I'm at
uh thank you Mr chairman so um I am uh
speaking against the itl motion
um in my opinion this is in no way shape
or form rent uh control all it is is
rent notification um it's a very simple
Bill If a landlord can absolutely
increase rent as much as he or she sees
fit uh just with the requirement of
adequate uh notification
um I I think that saying the system
isn't great as an understatement I
throughout my two terms we heard enough
personal testimony and from others of
people whose rent increased astronomical
amounts um with only having 30 days to
either find that amount of money or
Another Place uh to live I think that we
absolutely need to give Granite Staters
more time I I believe that uh this bill
is fair 60 days that exceeds five
percent or 90 days that exceeds eight
percent or more um so I think it's a
very fair bill and I urge um my
colleagues to vote this motion down to
another one can be offered thank you Mr
chairman
representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair I just want to
Echo representative Sylvia's points
um this is I believe a step towards rent
control I believe that 30 days is
adequate about her notice
um while I'm sympathetic in an advocate
um for more housing in the housing
crisis I believe that
um this the solution to that is on the
supply side and not further regulation
on our landlords who are already
experiencing huge amounts of regulations
especially during the cobit campaign so
um we need to vote this down thank you
and representative Morgan
thank you very much Mr chair I'll just
say that the uh rental housing market
here in New Hampshire is very very
different from what we learned in econ
101 so the you know
the supply and demand courage are not
like neatly processing each other at a
45 degree angles so uh I think
it's I mean this is not rent control and
it's certainly very far back to what was
uh
instituted in New York City 75 years ago
in which like doesn't really exist
anymore so um
I think
I think we need to we need we need at
least some sort of control over it and
this is just a very very basic thing
with uh lets the tenant know what the uh
what the cost is going to be because
this is very very different from an
Ideal Market you know the two sides of
Mark could have
you know there's a severe shortage of
rental housing and uh there's also like
a severe power imbalance between the two
sides and you certainly
this is one of many areas where how they
approach commercial leases is totally
different than part of the reason for
that is well first of all there's
not a shortage of commercial housing but
also like the uh you know the players
are you know they're playing against
people their own size you know in that
case the tenants have as much power as
the landlord sometimes more so this is
uh this is just a simple thing to level
the playing field you know this is a
residence housing market it's not like
we have an econ 101 and the Holy Show
Supply you know that's uh
that's a whole separate issue which is
beyond the scope of this bill and that's
uh I believe beyond the scope of this
committee but uh I don't think passing
is I don't think I don't think idealing
this bill is going to make anybody rush
out and build more uh rental housing so
I'm going to vote against cipl and
hopefully get past the bill thanks
thank you representative wolper thank
you Mr chairman uh Mr chairman one thing
we very law and clear is that uh the
rental market is tight and expensive
mostly because of regulations and every
regulation that we add increases the
cost decreases the availability and
makes the housing prices worse so I'm
any other
seeing none ask the clerk to call the
role on House Bill 160 this is on a
motion of inexpedient to legislate
the experience of legislative House Bill
160 represented in the point yes
representative Alexander yes
representative rice yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Thomas yes
representative for our year
yes
representative Marjorie Smith
no
representative bird no
representative
Oregon folks no
representative Lorenzo no
representative Chase no
no
representative
representative Macbeth no
no
representative Simpson no
Mr chairman
yes
[Music]
the motion for inexpecting to legislate
representative Kenny would you like to
do a Minority Report
House Bill 206 an act relative to
collective bargaining agreement strategy
discussions under the right to know law
[Music]
for a motion representative Wolford did
you have a motion on that
um
representative wolfer moves out to pass
and is there a second to that
I'll second
Ed by representative Sylvia
so
I sponsored a bill just about identical
to this last year
uh my opinion that we are the owners
of what happens during collected by
now which side which is the taxpayer
pays the taxpayers should know be able
to see
what's going on during these adult
patients so I was appalled with my
School board chairman and I was there at
my church one night and I asked him he
said oh I can't talk to you about what
we're negotiating I can't tell you
well it's excluded because we're doing
in the darkness negotiation
and now it's Paul I think it's a great
deal it's transparent it's an effect in
many states
what some states have partial open and
the modern states have totally open this
is to us
protect you to give the boards an
opportunity to develop your strategy or
whatever in private
but when it comes to the action
negotiations that should be in public
and we've heard from a testament
National people who are involved in
National negotiations such as if there's
a problem when that occurs
questions
Representatives representative Macbeth
um thank you Mr chair
um despite my respect for some of the
Prime sponsor and my colleagues um I
can't support the motion ought to pass I
I understand that this bill you know the
intent is to create transparency
although I feel like it it really will
do the opposite and it'll
um be detrimental to the um collective
bargaining process and because I think
it's going to increase
um maybe create some posturing and a
lack of Candor so I I urge my colleagues
to vote against the um odd to pass
seeing no one we do have a motion uh to
make the recommendation of ought to pass
and Mr clerk can you call a roll
hard to pass on Hospital 2006
representative acclaimed yes
Representatives yes
versus yes representative Alexander yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
yes
representative Margie Smith no
no
representative horse
Representative no
representative Chase no
no
representative language
representative page no
representative Simpson
no
representative McMath
are you interested in doing a Minority
Report yes I will on ought to pass
I mean on itl I apologize thank you okay
just making sure you're on your toes
thank you I really appreciate that
I was still
212 an act relative to drug courts and
for someone would like to make a lotion
on that representative De Lorenzo
IA I'd like to make a motion of itl on
this bill
is there a second on that
yeah
is that representative rice that made
the second Macbeth
representative
okay and would you like to address that
representative De Lorenzo yes Mr
chairman thank you this bill is
unnecessary
um the drug court program already
provides for the services
um mentioned in this bill so it allows
the offender to participate in social
work and mental health
consultations already and
we heard testimony from judge nario
um that the services are all already
available
um for 18 to 24 months
um
while the person is in the program and
we need to also think about the cost
of the bill right now the present drug
court is able to
Bill the participants medical insurance
and medical insurance covers about 90
percent of the cost of the program so
thank you any
seeing none I think Mr Clerk call the
role this is on House Bill 212 and the
motion is an expedient to legislation an
representative Sylvia
yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes
yes
representative Kelly yes
representative yes
is right here
yes
sorry yes
representative yes
representative page yes representative
Simpson yes
without objection to be placed on a
consent
um
I was building 216 and that relative to
public notice of and access to meetings
of the right to know representative
Smith had a question oh I'm sorry thank
you Mr chair I do have a question about
this bill as
um the news has been percolating through
the legislature that the um
speaker is working on adjusting our
calendar and changing our deadlines
so that we can
compact a time when we'll all be
together closer to the end of March and
the beginning of April because of that
the immediate urgency to vote on bills
is somewhat lessened we have an
amendment that has not yet come back
from OLS on this bill so I wonder if you
would consider
just delaying this and to put it perhaps
on the calendar for next week when we
will be um again uh executing bills and
that I don't think would add an undue
burden since it's only 10 12 and we've
already taken 12 votes so we're moving
right along
are you talking about House Bill 216
does anybody have any objection If We
Hold that to our next Executive Center
we are planning to have the executive
session next uh Wednesday a week from
why why don't uh
we'll hold off acting on House Bill 216.
in order to record uh representative
Smith the opportunity to get her
Amendment together
and we'll act on it
a plan to act on it next Wednesday
Hospital 227 that relative to
termination
at the expiration of the Tennessee or
and I would think the most
not to pass and would offer
McLean
[Music]
his Amendment
2021-0361h
made any representations with regard to
uh
to knowing it very supporting the bill
I'm completely enacted I didn't believe
that Elliott supported or did not object
to the amendment that was proposing but
he has never supported the bill
and to the extent that the amendment
the amendment uh
would have been the bill
he wouldn't support that as well he's my
good friend I just want to make it clear
that I'm not speaking for him at all
so
the
is indicate that if you are a landlord
and enter into a lease agreement that
you would be able to terminate at least
at the end of the term of the lease
without having to show that there was
and
because at least is in fact a contract
and so you enter into that contract
who are only agree
the landlord and the senator only agree
that they would have concession the
tenant could have possession of that
property before the turn of the least
and uh
and in many cases there is good reason
good cause for people to expect people
to leave at the turn at the end of the
turn of the lease
another current law it just doesn't
apply
so you may decide that you want to rent
your property
on newfound Lake and you wanted to live
for a year but then you have other plans
at the end of the year right now just
signing a lease and saying to turn this
a year isn't sufficient in order for
that to ask that person to leave at the
end of the year you have to show that
there's other good cause other than for
instance
so it makes sense I believe to
enforce the terms of the country
I think that that was the sponsorship
I think it has some unintended
consequence and that is
very common for landlords
to
enter into a one-year lease and then
allow people to hold
so you may have somebody that enters
into a one-year lease that release isn't
renewed and they're there for six years
well if that's the case
the way that the original bill was
written somebody can just terminate the
lease at the end of
terminate at least any time because the
the term of the lease is expired so six
years later you wouldn't have to show
cause you could just terminate the lease
and I don't think that's fair uh
certainly not fair
so the amount what the amendment does is
say yeah you can terminate the lease but
you have to do it uh
uh you have to provide notice to the
tenant before the lease term expires so
if you enter into a one-year lease you
would have to give the tenant 30 days
notice in advance that you're not going
to renew the lease and that you would
like them to vacation
and I think that that is a is reasonable
a reasonable expectation and I think it
makes the bill certainly more acceptable
to meet
and so I would
encourage people to support the
amendment
makes the bill better in any event
regardless of how you feel but I would
also ask you to support the
representative
thank you Mr chair for the question
um just to clarify the details of the
amendment
um I understand that the landlord would
have to give the 30-day notice for uh
for vacating the unit then would after
that 12-year mark would it just continue
out of 30 days or would it be extend for
another year and then the 30 days would
start again or is it just on a month by
month after that initial lease period no
uh if you enter into the written lease
basically if you don't renew the lease
if you don't renew the lease
then all bets are off then you have to
prove then you have to go back and you
have to prove a good cause for eviction
so and this has a I think the amendment
will have a positive effect because
right now so many landlords
very professionally Awards
have people redo their lease every year
let's do a new release renew every year
but the fact is that lots of landlords
aren't professional landlords and what
they do is a one-year lease that's very
typical to do a one-year lease and then
uh that's it and then the tenant just
stays there because the tenant has
proven to be a good tenant they want
them to stay there
I think if you put this amendment into
effect it'll have the effect of
encouraging landlords to renew their
lease every year which is a much better
practice and a much better practice for
everyone
but the fact is if you let your lease
spy
at least turns five
then after that you have to prove a good
I'm sorry I had a stuck Mount thank you
very much for your response appreciate
it
representative e Lorenzo thank you Mr
chair I have a question for you so once
the um 30-day notice is sent to the
tenant
does the landlord then have to take the
tenant to court to evict them I I think
that's a thank you that's a really good
question and a very good point because
you still have to go there's no way you
you don't just kick somebody out they
still have to take them to court so if
they don't leave the premises at the end
of the lease period they still have to
go through the normal eviction process
and
and then and that's what the whole issue
is about and that is what standard is
the court going to apply and in this
particular case this would change the
law to say that it would have a fixed
term on your lease
you a landlord gets to evict a tenant at
the end of the term of that lease and it
makes a lot of sense because
people enter into agreements and they
enter into the lease and then they find
out their tenant is a lousy tenant
frankly
they don't keep the place clean you know
I could tell you as a judge you hear
these stories all the time about they
have a non-smoking apartment and the
people are smoking in it but they could
never catch them smoking in it but they
know they are because of the smell in it
and they want them out at the end of the
least term and it makes sense to give
them the opportunity if they have a
defined lease in order to be able to get
them out but then you go to court and
and that Court you still have to prove
that it's the end of the lease term
and that you have a right to have them
out and then the court has discretion to
give the tenants up to 90 days in order
to vacate the premises
and it's very typical for judges to give
a reasonable period of time not uncommon
for 30 days for people to vacate even
questions
because this isn't the Amendments
Amendment 0361h
yes
representative Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
representative yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh yes
representative
yes
no
representative
yes
Mr chairman
[Music]
17-4 is adopted the amendment and now
yes
representative yes
representative price
yes
representative
representative Kelly yes
representative Todd
yes
no
representative Morgan
representative Chase oh
representative Kenny
no
represented mainly
representative
yes
no
foreign
it's German
yes
Oregon
12 tonight adopted the recommendation of
octopus as amended
could we get back to you on that a
little later
Mr chair today
I do want to make sure that everybody
gets their reports in tomorrow by
tomorrow sometimes against the emails
Hospital 236 not creating a statute of
limitation on civil actions relative to
damage caused by
yeah
it's their emotion representative McLean
a second
Sylvia
representative plain is moving in
expedient to legislate and that's
you want to address your motion yeah
thank you Mr chair
um I have a lot of Sympathy for the
concerns around feedback but um I think
that the three years is adequate
especially given the fact that this bill
really doesn't change the time outwards
the clock starts ticking which is at the
point of reasonable Discovery so even if
you're 20 or 25 years out or if there's
new information brought to bear that
would alter that then the the clock
basically starts again because that's
when this new information is discovered
so I really don't see uh the need and in
addition what it does is it creates a
special cargo for uh pfas itself and so
I think as we go down the road and we
discover other substances I can see the
creation of a patchwork in the future
where we're going to be coming back
let's add this and it's going to be this
not to that much so I think really for
me the central point is the clock starts
ticking at the point of reasonable
Discovery that's unchanged I don't think
this bill is necessary and I'm
yes representative page
thank you Mr chair
um I I would impose the motion for itl
for a number of reasons I think this is
a law that catches up with the science
as we know the law moves slowly I think
this is a particularly relevant in this
case because we know how difficult it is
to uh prove toxic tort cases as we heard
testimony on that point
um I think in terms of the carve out
issue this makes sense with pfas because
this is a bunch of them this is in a
suite of emerging contaminants these are
things that the science is learning
about in the context of pfas these are
the the um negative health effects such
as
low infant birth weights asthma
increased cancer rates and then
particularly
impactful on children
are latent to develop so it makes sense
that we would extend the normal what
would we would consider a typical normal
statute of limitations on a
negligence claim of three years to six
years given that what we now know by way
of science with respect to
um the pfas chemical it's still the
causal element Still Remains so
um these are difficult cases to win
um so it's not it's not an easy win but
I think this recognizes a particular
problem that we have in New Hampshire
with a particular chemical that is
particularly problematic so thank you
and I would oppose the itl thank you
representative Oregon
basically well Brandon Paige probably
said exactly one one to say but I just
want to say a carfa for this is
entirely justifiable because we have a
we have frankly is a a crisis and um
these cases are going to be very
difficult to prove I think the Carvel is
appropriate and the extra
time periods are probably just because
it's so pervasive many cases
the leaders are very powerful
corporations who are very good at
defending themselves and of the
consequences are
for those except for the damages are
very serious so I think this is uh I
think this bill is a small first step to
once again as I cliche I used before
which is leveling the playing field so I
I think a carve out this is entirely
justifiable
um so that's lame
[Applause]
Cena we do have a motion pending it's
I didn't experience a legislate up until
236 represent yes
representative Alexander yes
yes Representative Steve Smith yes
representative gray yes
representative Kelly yes
representative thought
yeah
representative
yes
Representative no
representative
no
representative Chase no
Representative no
no
Mr chairman yes
yes
motion has been defeated
is there another emotion representative
page
yes I'd make a motion to ought to pass
and um I won't elaborate more on the
points that I already made with regard
to opposing the itls I think all of
those the time time has come I think for
the science to catch up
a lot of catch up to the science as I
said before I think this makes sense in
the context of New Hampshire we hear
plenty of testimony about the impact of
pfas here and I think it's time for
passage and I would vote to ought to
pass and who's seconding
about the past let's pass on Hospital
236 representative McLean no
representative Silvis no
now
representative rice no
yeah no
representative Kelly no
representative
yes
no
representative
um yes
representative Bert yes
representative
president of Oregon votes yes
yes
representative yes
Mr chairman no
um
I got this recommendation would like to
pass
I'm going to be a Minority Report yes
Matt Mr chair I'm sorry I I didn't hear
anything you said
yes uh the ought to pass motion was
adopted 11 to 10.
and that representative McLean is going
Hospital 287 an act relative to remote
motorization
representative McLean thank you Mr chair
um I would make a motion of uh uh the
is that 70 by anybody
I think I think there's Samaritan to the
bill but the Mortgage Bankers
Association mentioned in testimony that
the Senate was working on something
comparable and uh so they were
developing some language there so I
think
um if we retain it it gives us an
opportunity to see the product that the
Senate generates and gives us some
representative McBeth
thank you Mr chair um I would agree and
um with my colleagues that comments and
I I support the retention of this Bill
seeing none Mr Claire can you call a
role in hospital 287 this is on a motion
to retain and committee
to retain House Bill 287 representative
yes
representative Sylvia
resentment Steve Smith yes
representative green yes
yes
representative
representative Morgan yes
yes
representative
representative yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
yes
we have voted to retain House Bill 287
yeah I I think the clerk has to renew
his forms for one thing but we've been
going for an hour and a half and if we
could take about 10 or 15 minutes for
everybody to get rid of their money
cloth
[Music]
a copy
it's like put these are here to make
more
I can't hear you yes
yes do you have more of these forms
which form do you need the exact the
exact sheet I need one more rule to
actually some more executive session
okay I'll get those for you and bring
foreign
[Music]
okay
screen
here
hey Jenna you it just takes one so she's
there is she just coming down to give it
to you she said she'd break it down she
may be uh walking down to give him those
papers
there
but it wasn't long right
10 or 15 years you were stuck 10 or 15
minutes
I don't know about you guys but I'm
fairly certain my house is going to blow
yeah I've actually had power been
flickering off and on during our break
so hopefully I've been stable now for
the last five minutes so hopefully yeah
good
so we're just waiting for Jen to take
down our recess screen and we'll get to
something
I did send everyone the hopefully final
Amendment for HB 540 you can pull that
out
okay we'll call this meeting of the
house Judiciary Committee backed up
order
our next bill to address this morning's
House Bill 360 and that relative to
I would uh offer
if
make a motion of ought to pass
a second
to offer an amendment
yes are we on 360. we are okay yeah so
foreign
we heard this bill this is with regard
to Shared living facilities and there
were questions raised as to whether or
not it needed more specific definition
this amendment came from
uh Elliott Berry actually he's the one
who raised the issue of the hearing
and he proposed this amendment which he
represented to me in his email he had
reviewed uh with Mr Norman as well and
that they were in agreement on the
amendment
and what it does is require that the
tenant identify in the petition in the
petition that's filed under 540b
that there be a check box on the circuit
Court's form petition that the rental
unit is governed by 540b which is in
fact the shared living facilities law
and not under 548 a which is for the
yes representative Smith
thank you very much
um Mr chair
can you
um give me your
either your legislative or your judicial
advice that's up to you does this
amendment address effectively
the need or the the need for a
definition
I
I don't believe it provides a definition
of the facilities I don't know without
going back and looking at the statute as
to whether or not they're further
oh Mr chair that's a disappointing
response um because
my concern is there seems to be so much
confusion
um around what exactly a shared facility
is and I see that this amendment uh does
attempt to clarify which specific
section which specific RSA
is relevant
and
um
I guess I just need assurance that it is
enough
specificity so that we're not making
I'm not sure I can give you that
specificity
I'm sorry I didn't hear you I'm not sure
I can give you that specificity thank
you well you're enough with it
representative Smith
it's representative
thank you Mr chair so I am I just want
to share my colleagues opinion I thought
I felt favorably about the testimony but
I I couldn't believe it I mean I've
never heard of this type of living
situation and we don't have it here in
Portsmouth so and when I think there was
a question about it and she's like well
everybody knows what it is it's like no
I don't know what it is and then so I I
could is this could we possibly retain
this to make sure that we have a
definition of what exactly we're talking
about
um you know what type of living
situation this is
frankly I'd be perfectly happy
I'm sorry I I meant excuse me if I could
follow up
I I meant if we could even hold it until
if we're going to hold any bills maybe
we could hold this one so that we could
check on that definition or add it to it
because it does it seems like a narrow
um group of people that if we could help
them I don't have a problem with that so
I didn't mean retain I'm you know we
could just
recess this here this part executive
session and pick it up next week after
the questions are answered I'll defer to
the chair
thank you
thank you thank you Mr chair I was just
wondering if it'd be helpful at all if I
read the share the definition from 540b
and people can hear
if it sounds would that be helpful that
would be helpful
yes please a shared facility means
rental means real property rented for
residential purposes which has separate
sleeping areas for each occupant and in
which each occupant has access to and
shares with the owner of the facility
one or more significant portions of the
facility in common such as kitchen
dining area bathroom or bathing area for
which the occupant has no rented right
of sole personal use
and then there are several
um exclusions a shared facility does not
shall not include facilities rented to
transient guests intended for use of
less than 90 days rooms and hotels
motels ins tourist homes and other
dwellings rented for recreational or
vacationing use
rooms provided ancillary to other
primary purposes such as jails dorms
student dorms nursing homes hospitals
is that
help uh representative McBeth with your
question
absolutely I I'm sorry I didn't think
about reading the statute we know how
important that is don't we thank you so
much uh representative Simpson thank you
representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair I think uh
representative
um
did a great job so you're reading the
statute and I think that this bill is
very straightforward with the um
Amendment and I think we should pass it
thank you
representative Smith thank you I I
agreed that does give us enough
specificity and of course as we know the
amendment requires
um the specific RSA citation so I
well we have the motion pending and
on the amendment first so if there is no
other discussion we'll take a vote on
the amendment
to the doctor said
05138 to hospital 360.
should be playing
yes
representative Sylvia
representative Alexander yes
representative rice yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
representative yes representative Kelly
yes
representative Thomas
yeah
representative Marjorie Smith yes
Bert
yes
representative Oregon uh yes
representative language yes
represent the best
yes
representative page yes
representative
yes and for the record that was my son
trying to get my attention before the
vote and not a nefarious actor if you
is
unless there's some discussion uh
take a vote on the
first
representative Alexander yes
representative Bryce yes
yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh
yes
representative Troyer
representative Marjorie Smith yes
yes
representative Hornby yes
representative Chase yes
representative Kenny yes
representative language
yes
representative Macbeth
representative page yes
representative Simpson yes
yes
system
[Music]
apologize I have to leave I have a
family emergency I've I've got to go
okay
sorry to hear that I'm so sorry
[Applause]
we're going to uh we'll proceed with our
executive session today but I'm going to
be sensitive to the fact that we have a
member missing and we'll deal with that
next is House Bill 368 an act relative
yeah
thank you Mr chair
um I uh move uh ought to pass on HB uh
368 and offer Amendment zero four nine
four h
which I think I'm about to everybody on
[Applause]
representative Chase sentence the motion
we want to address your Amendment okay
um well uh yeah I think the
with the amendment uh
the reason I'm off for the amendment is
in in the public hearing I ask
representative Cushing the question uh
which was
since the governor had vetoed this uh in
the last session what really was
different and his response was you know
there's a higher level of urgency but
really I think that the governor did
raise some concerns but I think what we
have to understand is that the g e is
really out of the bottle with respect to
Medical monitoring
um courts are starting to recognize that
we had the Herman's versus TCI case at
Hillsboro Superior Court which
um authorized sort of by the class
action and yeah
Federal District Court uh there
certified
um for medical monitoring so the
question really is
are we going to leave all this to the
courts or are we as the legislature
going to be a voice in that discussion
and show some leadership in that
discussion we can be practical
Governor vetoed it last time around with
this but this amendment does is it looks
at uh Vermont amendment that
um the governor of Vermont who also
vetoed medical monitor legislation in
Vermont said he would support medical
monitoring legislation if there was an
amendment that clarified
um the nature of of the Harem and so
what this amendment does is it
incorporates that by adding one term and
that one term if you read is the
plaintiff now suffers from a
significantly increased risk so just the
addition of that one term significantly
increased risk that actually adds a lot
of clarity and the reason that it adds
Clarity is because the terms
significantly is a statistically
universally accepted term so I think it
really takes a lot of the fuzziness out
of it any statistician anywhere in the
world when they do hypothesis testing
understands what a significantly
increased risk is there's hard
statistical rules around that and this
is the language that the Vermont
Governor said if it was incorporated he
would support that kind of medical
monitoring legislation so my hope is by
doing this we can go back to the house
we can go back to the governor and we
can say this is the change that we've
made and this is why you should rethink
your position on the detail so that's
the nature of the amendment going to
yes representative Chase
I just want to agree with representative
McLean we've done a really lot of hard
work on this looked at it from every
angle I like the amendment and I would
hope that we can
yeah anyone else
seen that Mr strickler this will be a
vote on the amendment this is amendment
2021.0494h
representative McLean yes
president Sylvia no
workbook yes
now
everybody
no
representative
now
yes
representative diorenzo yes
representative Penny yes
yes
good yes
representative Simpson
yes
no
it has
12.
you've adopted the amendment we're back
to the motion uh hard to pass as amended
just one thing uh Mr chairman if I could
yeah
I think on this uh there was a strong
case made that essentially you're
tapping into a limited pool of money
and additional monies that are spent on
medical monitoring for people who don't
necessarily need it
takes away from those who are in need so
yeah so Mr chairman now that I will also
be voting against this bill I just don't
think we should be enacting this into
law
I don't think that we need to create
this new resort situation
[Applause]
representative Chase
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee I just want to say I I also
heard that about having depleted funds
and businesses going out this with the
amendment the way I read it and the work
that we've been doing this is showing if
somebody is showing significant
suffering now significantly from an
increased risk of an illness it's not
just for anybody who thinks that they've
been exposed but bringing that up to
your doctor that you have been exposed
at some time or you feel you have well
just keep that in the records and also
give it the um opportunity that if
something does start to come up that it
can look back to be related to what had
happened within the water system or the
ground I don't feel that this is just
people signing up raising their hands
saying I think I was disposed I need you
to now monitor me this is um lot of care
there's been a lot of people that have
been heard from this and we're going to
find there a lot more I urge you please
representative
oh thank you very much well this is a
view this same comment about the earlier
chill about the pfast at this uh this is
a uh hopefully when this works right
it's a preventative uh preventative
measure so the medical monitoring can uh
first of all people's minds at ease if
they're I don't have any diseases of
British culture but also like it will uh
they'll find they'll detect the disease
and treat it sooner so that'll save a
lot of suffering and I'm also
I believe the asbestos uh
cases came up with John's management
it's just a full disclosure my my uh
late father was a member of the class
which had many millions of people for
the Asbestos and certainly uh
you know we
the amount of money we got with minimal
comparative amount of suffering he had
and he was vastly more fortunate than a
lot of other people so you know this uh
you know you don't want to so so I think
anything any type of suffering we can
prevent that that's good and I think the
I don't think the cost of this is
excessive unless of course they detect
the disease and then they that the whole
other
that's a whole other uh issue but
anyways I think this is a this is a good
see none
uh Mr clerk would you call the role this
is on a motion of octopus with the
amendment
368.04948 is remain yes
representative Sylvia no
[Music]
representative
Smith C Smith
now
representative degree
you know
representative Kelly
no
representative
yeah
no
now
representative Margie Smith yes
yes
yes representative Morgan
well I'm voting yes and also I am and I
don't feel the personal interest that I
disclosed earlier which probably others
don't think that rises the level of
conflict of interest that uh of
representative Kenny yes
representative
yes
representative page
representative Simpson
yes
can you give that number again
in the affirmative nine in the negative
thank you you've adopted the motion
about to pass as amended
and representative Wolverine you need to
do a minority before
[Applause]
384 an act prohibiting the sharing of
representative Smith would you like to
make a motion uh yes I would move
ought to pass Mr chair
and is there a second to that
Sylvia
hey would you like to address your
motion
um thank you very much Mr chair yes I
would um address my motion
um this bill has to do with prohibiting
the sharing of location data
um
I have long been and continue to be an
advocate for privacy
um I think that uh
that personal privacy is an important
component of uh of how we can live our
free lives in this country I believe
very strongly that this should be a
matter
addressed confidently and intelligently
on the federal level in fact it would be
most effective if this was a national
policy but one of the great benefits
that we have from our form of government
is that many sound ideas were tried out
first in States and when then people in
various states were able to see that it
does work and it makes sense that has
moved our federal officials to find the
courage and the knowledge to take
appropriate action and so while I don't
think that the ideal answer is to have
this handled on a state-by-state basis
the Journey of a Thousand Miles begins
with one step and I believe this is a
solid first step for this state to take
in protecting
um
in an appropriate responsible way
representative Alexander
um thank you thank you Mr chair
um
while I am sympathetic to representative
Smith's uh coins I am going to oppose
this bill
um I do believe it needs to be a
national policy and that's why I
recommend uh representative Smith
reached out to her congressmen so we can
get this rolling
um I believe having federal or worldwide
companies we write policies for one out
of 50 states it's uh not really a
productive way of doing things
um I think that there was a problem with
um sharing of aggregate data by
companies so they can perform the best
way possible in big cities and I think
this really adversely affects the gig
economy we should be pursuing avenues
that allow the gig economy to grow and I
think location data helps them really
figure out where their customers are and
where they're moving so I just in
general that this is a bad Bill that
hurts Innovation the gig economy and uh
doesn't support
thank you
[Applause]
so
there's nothing that stops the company
like Uber or any of these other
economies
from using the data to take water for
their own purposes or to satisfy
requests for from the individual or
other services that they might desire as
long as they request it or in this broad
exemptions the law enforcement or
emergency situations and all those types
of things those are Exempted out of this
bill this is about
those companies taking your personal
data and we had we had testimony during
the year
the gentleman who was the actual driver
that still brought it to our attention
two years ago
in 15 minutes putting in his own phone
number
to find out enormous amounts of
information by himself
I'm worried about the things that he had
done this is not right
this should be stopped if we can only do
New Hampshire that we just do it in New
Hampshire
so that's not uh the amendment that I
offer is uh Amendment 0155
it it replaces the applicability
paragraph
thanks
big difference between the bill this
year and last year is that last year we
Felix about what providers this year
we're talking about developers and much
broader spectrum of the people to whom
this would apply
and some of our other some language gets
snuck into that paragraph about where
the bad thing so hard to the language we
used last year was very well accepted by
this committee
to make it clear that we're just talking
about
the information and the type position
not exactly where it was required so
that's where the one five five minutes
got so and I would like to amend a
okay so we have uh then that's been
offered by representative
Mr Speaker I would be happy
um to remove my
um motion
of just ought to pass
um if it makes things neater from the
point of view or process and um and if
the seconder agrees I would then move
otpa
uh with with representative goldfish
yes
I second that
you agree with that representative
Sylvia yes
representative so we're actually looking
4155h but we need to do two books right
we'll do two votes but representative
Verge
yes it's more directed towards the
overall build which regretfully I will
not be able to support I think it's
number one it's it's too broad
and one of the areas where I think it's
too broad is it makes no effective uh
division between the collection of
anonymous data and non-anonymous data
and I know for instance and that's a big
difference they're used for different
purposes and uh others if we want to go
state by state which is a bad way of
doing it uh at least we should take a
look at what other states have found not
to be a good idea in California found
that lumping together Anonymous
collection and non-anonymous collection
was a bad idea and they separated it
into two different areas
I'm concerned that
um
this bill is so broad it may affect the
ability of
my my credit card company or whatever or
Amazon to call me and say there's a
purchase made in Monaco
you know four thousand dollars worth of
handbags are you sure you did that
and I just point out would probably say
no I didn't
and I
it's easy just to say privacy privacy
privacy but we still need to have
legislation that's clear concise and
avoids uh
collateral consequences that we may not
like
thank you
representative Smith did you wish to
um I I don't think so thank you
representative Morgan I'm sorry my hand
was up I didn't realize
um thank you very very much Mr chair I
mean I think this feels too broad it's a
federal issue and also
doesn't address the problem what happens
when somebody there's lots of things we
do in the web where your location is
part of the point of it like uh like
today when you post pictures of yourself
on Facebook or uh I guess it doesn't
exist anymore but parlor or whatever
which um
and um a lot of times you're literally
you advertise you write a location
deliberately or maybe the integral part
of the service and then
and then
and then you have regrets later so
that's not really a social media site 12
but it does seem like a
uh there's a lot of does that seem like
people often like
if you're trying to get people from
getting trouble because uh some somebody
knows where they are a lot of times just
because you've deliberately advertised
where you are but then somebody else is
using the service uh doesn't like the
fact that you were there so that's uh
they just feel it that's just one of our
multitude of problems with this build so
I think it's uh I think it's not it's
not ready to pass so it should be itl
thanks
thank you representative Walter thank
you Mr chairman and I just want to
respond to this as far as a
disaggregated data that's not attached
then if you publicly share your location
then that makes that public and it's no
longer subject to a privacy interest
so I don't see why that would be
involved so I don't see it that was a
if not we'll be voting on the amendment
and with regard to the adoption of that
Amendment and representative wolper Mr
Clark would you call a roll on that on
adopting Amendment goal 155h to hospital
384 representative employee yes
representative yes
representative
Representative Steve Smith
yes
representative degree yes
representative Kelly
yes
representative
representative chartier
yes
representative yes
representative
or is it Oregon not right how Oregon
feel snow in the amendments
yes
representative yes
representative page
yes
representative yes
another discussion we now have adopted
Amendment 0155h back to the motion of
ought to pass as amended
and Mr Clark saying no hands up if you
want to call the roll on
House Bill 384 on the record motion of
recommending on the passes
representing the client yes
representative Alexander now
Representative Steve Smith yes
yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Josh yes
representative Charlie here
yes
representative Margie Smith
representative
again no
representative yes
representative serious
yes
representative page
anybody have any objection to putting
that on the consent calendar
yes
um yes I think we'll probably would
might get pulled off to considering
calendar anyway but I'll
put in the regular calendar is it your
intention to do a Minority Report
representative
um I
I haven't decided yet so uh no okay
yeah
is that a maybe or but maybe yeah
when when will you have an answer to
that oh okay well I'll have an answer
okay I'll change my maybe to yes I'll
Mr chair
yes um although I made the motion
um the prime sponsor is a member of the
committee that is a representative
welper and I would like to ask if he um
would like to write the committee report
uh
for the calendar
yes
okay
oh
foreign
because we don't have the full committee
right now
is I would like to skip over House Bill
440. I know that that would be important
to representative rice and wait and see
whether or not she's able to join us
this afternoon if that's okay with
everybody
absolutely
okay the next uh the next bill would be
HP 453 in action
mandatory disclosure of sources by
subpoena
is there a
on that
representative representative Alexander
um thank you Mr chair I want to move on
hb453 and experience
is there a second to that
and you want to address that yes Mr
chair
um I think I really think there's a lack
of definition on what if what a
journalist is
um I think it really I think it's kind
of a claw and I think that
um freedom of speech or freedom of the
there's a there's a clear definition on
journalism
[Applause]
it's not Mr clerk I think you can call a
role this is on a motion on House Bill
453 of anything you need to legislation
experience
yes
representative Sylvia yes
no
yes
representative Kelly
representative yes
yes
representative language
representative
yes
representative yes
representative Simpson
yes
you've adopted the recommendation of
inexpediate legislate by a vote of 18 to
two is there any objection to having
singer
an act creating surveillance by the
representative Sylvia if you want to
make
you're muted
oh gee I got caught there didn't I I
would move what to pass and I believe I
so representative has moved out to pass
and
going to offer an amendment is there
I I would second it
I saw a representative oh Simpsons
Simpsons
okay
30 minutes
yeah do you have the amendment number
Mike
I would love to but I've uh reached the
I have to do a little bit of scrambling
if anyone wants to uh help by all means
jump in
the amendment is Mr chair yes
um the amendment is relatively short
would it help you representative Sylvia
if I read the amendment
yeah sure
Mr chair would that be
and then the bill by replacing all after
section two with the following
three new sub paragraph Highway
surveillance prohibited Amanda RSA 236
133 by inserting after sub paragraph G
the following new subparagraph
H is undertaken for security and to
facilitate law enforcement in the
investigation of criminal activity at
properties under the jurisdiction of the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources provided that no video
recording shall be stored longer than 24
days except if needed in a Judicial or
administrative proceeding in a
particular case
the properties on which surveillance
occurs shall display signage indicating
the presence of 24-hour video cameras
effective date this shall take effect
thank you
so do you have any further comment
representative Sylvia
call four six one h
any other comments
on the bill or the amendment
are you ready to vote
it's
resources because they have situations
and
so and they don't really deal with the
public ways the way we talk we normally
well
[Music]
474 representative plan yes
yes
representative yes
Mr President Steve Smith yes
representative green yes
yes
representative
now
represented Marjorie Smith yes
[Music]
representative Horrigan
no sorry no
representative diorenzo yes
I don't see him Mr Clark he message me
yesterday
yes
representative Macbeth yes
representative yes
yes
before we begin this boat
I just want to make sure representative
Kenny
available let me see what's happening
the chair is waiting for your program
[Laughter]
Mr chair if you could wait a moment a
representative Kenny
um has lost his coverage but he is going
to come and show his face
on my screen so he can vote is that okay
great
turn right
and I should be back on mine in like two
we'll do one more bill after this and
it's like a plan
Mr chair I apologize but with that
Interruption I didn't get the final vote
on the amendment eighteen to two thank
you very much
[Music]
we will vote on the bill
ought to pass as amended as soon as
representative Kennedy gets back online
um he can come up and do this again so
don't delay for him okay well then thank
you
this is House Bill 474 plus any further
discussion I see or he ended up
representing Soviet is that
if uh
that if that's if you're not looking to
speak then uh Mr clerk why don't you
call the the role on House Bill 474 this
is on the motion a lot to pass is a
minute
yes
representative yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
yes
now
so
representative
no
representative changed yes
representative Kerry yes
representative
yes
represented like that
representative Simpson
yes
negative
so you've adopted the
recommendation of octopus pass as
they said it
earlier we will do uh
guys does anybody have an objection to
foreign
then what we'll do is plan a break for
lunch after that
so you do have
let's go 540 this is an act relative to
supportive decision making and it's an
alternative to guardianship
representative Chase if you want to make
a motion I do I'd like to make an
emotion uh to pass with Amendment
and I would like to refer to the
amendment that you should have received
Ence
and is there a second to oh I'm sorry
that motion
okay go ahead representative chicks all
right I want to
know the amendment and again that is oh
five six five h
uh there was a little bit of concern
with the statement of findings and
relative to
a
disability is
we talked about this quite a bit I did
agree with that yet I didn't find that
it had a lot to do with the body and of
the bill but it was not needed so that
has been removed
and also there were a couple of other
amendments that came through that have
been incorporated into this and those
are in regards to the IEP team and what
a they would do with a student or family
the team shall inform the student and
the family of the ability to support
decision making in pursuant to RSA
464--d as an alternative to guardianship
it should be done promptly when
guardianship is first discussed
team should make available resources and
assist in establishing a support
decision-making agreement
if that is executed the IEP team shall
abide by the decisions made by the
student pursuant to the reported
decision making agreement
um and basically that's it we just tried
to
clear up what possibly was considered
and I'd hate to use this but offensive
and I agree language about
um the definition of disabled in the
subject
statement of findings and the rest is
just the work that's been done with the
stakeholders
and task force group that has been
working on this
so I would urge you if to vote for the
amendment and then ought to pass on the
bill
thank you Mr chairman
um
I'm basically
sort of supportive of the bill I'm not
leading either particular way I was
certainly concerned with the uh
the
unconscious bias that made its way into
the findings originally and having only
had a little while and essentially
reading the amendment while we're doing
this and falling behind on my other work
uh for which I apologize
um
I
I would like more time to consider this
uh so I I don't I don't feel like I'm
prepared to vote for this at this time
see I ask a question
yeah just just hold on I'm going to call
upon uh represent Macbeth first and I'll
come back to you representative Chase
I apologize to the committee I just
hadn't lowered my hand thank you I
support this amendment but I I didn't
raise my hand representative McLean yeah
I I just want to Echo
um representative Sylvia's comments
while on broadly supportive of this I'm
just getting the amendment uh at 10
o'clock and so I'm just looking at it
now I haven't really had time to process
it so uh in light of that if we could
maybe hold off a little bit
they could just ask representative
Sylvia are you uh when you say to put
off making a determination on it are you
talking about maybe putting it off till
next Wednesday or are you talking about
retaining it until next week well
you know I'm not as you've seen I'm not
a fan of the retention
um
perhaps by next Monday we could have
some input from folks you know with
disabilities uh because obviously they
are more sensitive to the language than
certainly I would be um you know more or
less pretty whole although you know I
have my defects
um so next next Wednesday would be fine
would that be okay with you
representative Chase
I do not have a problem with that at all
and I am also willing to remove the
statement of findings completely if that
is still a question to people after they
read the amendment and still don't feel
comfortable with it
imagine that you I'm not muted
um
um if representative Chase and
representative Simpson would pull back
um their motion
um with uh respect for them and for
representative Sylvia's comments I don't
think any of us have had a chance to
really reflect
um in detail on this amendment and I
would hope that the chair would agree
that
um we added to next Wednesday's uh
calendar and that would give people a
time to look at the amendment and
um
consider any further changes that they
representative Macbeth
I'd support that what
oops
it's okay
so
I I have certainly have no objection
that I'm presuming that representative
Chase and representative Simpsons shoot
withdraw your immediate devotions
withdraw my emotion
well we'll plan to address House Bill
540 that our session
next one a week from this Wednesday
be our last
executive session
of House business
okay
okay so why don't we break for lunch and
come back at uh one o'clock you you guys
have just done great going through these
bills today
thank you so much everybody
we'll see you at one o'clock
what what time is it we're coming back
foreign
[Applause]
much
us
hello everyone we're back from Recess
and so I'll call the water this
I my account we have eight more bills to
the
the issue that I'm faced with is that we
have several of these bills which I know
uh and I've tried to reach out uh to uh
representative Bryce
uh but I have not heard back from her
and don't actually know what her
circumstances are
I know some of the bills are going to be
bills where we're going to have uh I
my
count we're going to have some very very
close votes and her vote may very well
make a difference on the outcome of
those
recommendations that we make
so um
somewhat reluctant to go forward on
those bills where I I think her vote
would uh make a substantial difference
in
might want to if we're able to um those
particular bills
consider
continuing them or recessing them and
hearing them next Wednesday with the
remainder of our bills
but we do have some bills which I think
we can take care of today
they have some hands
representative Hardin
um yes for planning purposes
um the meeting we're having on Friday I
mean it does have the usual notice about
executive
successes may be met by your your
anticipation is that would be purely a
day for hearings
uh the only thing that's scheduled right
now is hearings but we are capable of
having executive session
I've I've tried to be very careful
with the executive sessions so that I
make sure that everybody is available
and incorporate them in the last few
hearings we've had we haven't
necessarily had everybody available
today
to do an executive session so I haven't
been having them
but the fact is that we could do
executive session on some bills
if we elected to do so
on Friday
you know fair enough reasons for
planning purposes is I have something
scheduled at at three and I could
reschedule it with enough advance notice
but um I'll uh
but I'll play it by years so thanks
no I'm trying to be as inclusive as
everybody for everybody and that's why I
sort of scheduled these separate days
for the executive session so people
could plan for sure to be there or find
a substitute
thanks
and Care excuse me representative Kenny
thank you Mr chairman I'm just for the
record my power is back so I've returned
back to my own apartment I am here uh
roommates uh are in the apartment and
maybe throughout the room uh for the
rest of the exec thank you
thank you
and representative Smith
thank you I guess I should say that my
solitary confinement which was
interrupted for a few hours this morning
is now back and I'm alone again and it
was very nice to have someone uh a floor
away but um I do want to say that I
thank you very much for the care that
you have demonstrated in announcing in
advance when you were going to exec I
think that's best for the committee and
it's best for the public
um and I uh the current schedule for
next Wednesday isn't exhausting
certainly the way this one could have
been so
um as I look at the afternoon I see
three bills that I can identify where
I'm pretty sure the sense of the
committee will be if not completely
uh unanimous be significantly so and
perhaps we could go ahead with those and
then you still would have time to put in
the calendar an amended notice for next
Wednesday to which you could add all of
the bills that we would like to defer
until then and I
um
I I and and I would encourage that
because I think that's best for public
notice and for the committee planning
with that uh that's exactly what I would
like to do I and if I'm not in it if we
don't if I don't have the same three
bills representative Smith you let me
know but
I think the next bill I call would be
[Applause]
Senator Macbeth would you like to make a
motion on that
[Applause]
um itl
and I'd like to speak on my motion if
there's a second yeah if there are a
second for that
by representative Alexander
yes go ahead and speak thank you Mr
chair so um I think that the you know
the representative that brought this
bill really shows what you know the
citizen legislature is all about uh
constituent had come to him with a quite
you know a concern and um he's brought
the bill to
um the legislature you know he's had a
full hearing
um you know he was able to speak with
the the Chief Justice at the superior
court and you know the representatives
from the administrative Court in the
drug court I I think that all those
stakeholders really heard the concerns
that he was his client his constituent
had and um you know
I well while I'm italing the bill
um I do think that he serves as his well
and I felt that his the concerns about
the drug court in this need for
um the other context the other um
um vocational help I I think that the
stakeholders answered that well but uh
again I think that it's heightened their
sensitivity to the need for that so um I
any other discussion this is on House
Bill 569 and on the motion of uh
seeing none call upon the clerk to draw
the role again this is on the motion of
IPL
yes
representative yes
representative green
yes
representative Kelly yes
representative
my money yes
yes
representative Simpson yes
no objection to the consent calendar
nope
they uh I think the next
bills that I think we can work on would
be house bill 584.
[Applause]
so
yeah
you'd like to I'd like to make a motion
seconded by representative Birch
and would you like to address that
representative
it appears that
pass not needed and it could possibly be
in violation of the U.S Constitution and
the New Hampshire Constitution
um
I know that members of the press
are
opposed to the bill
and
you
any other discussion on House Bill 584
yes I think
I I think um I think maybe uh when the
bill was written they also
underestimated uh the ability of media
consumers to uh
know that the old stories are old
stories and there's probably a newer
story from you know things have happened
since then too like
I know I was on the front page of a
union leader for doing something stupid
about 10 years ago and um
actually pretty rare that anybody brings
it up but when they do you know I know
I've done lots of other things lots of
other stupid things and occasionally
some not so stupid things since then I
think that's the case for most
individuals who have old stories about
themselves in the newspaper and also of
course we want
the media to report more more news not
less you know so I would
and of course I agree it's totally
unconstitutional as well so I think
that's just
[Applause]
this is an emotion of shakespeed to
legislate on House Bill 584
[Music]
e
yes
representative Sylvia yes
Representative Steve Smith yes
representative green yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Tosh yes
representative Troyer
yes
representative
uh for yes
yes
yes sorry I thought it was it yes yes
representative
yes
representative language
representative yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson
yes
Mr chairman
okay about being 20 to zero
foreign
yes representative Smith no I'm just
the next bill
now are you ready
president Smith
thank you very much yes Mr chair
what would I expect that
representative
um
yes thank you very much
um Mr chair
um I don't think there is anyone on this
committee
who does not believe
that
um
uh the way
we educate our children in a Democratic
Society
that's a small D Democratic Society is
essential
um
to
um our social cultural economic
um
survival and I don't think there is
anyone
in this committee if certainly speaking
for myself who does not believe that we
haven't
necessarily found the absolute best way
to provide appropriate educational
opportunities for every citizen
of this state really from
from birth until
death
um
and we recognize the complexity
so I have great
sympathy for representative lewicki for
raising this issue and do not want to
say anything in any way to minimize the
importance of the issue that he raises
but I believe very strongly
that the reason we are called
Representatives is because we represent
all of the people in the state
and more than any other state
each of us represents
a smaller number of people and therefore
are at least in theory closer to the
people we represent
it is because of that that I believe it
is important that it is the legislative
body
that focuses on how to
shape
access to and funding for
quality public education for all
the courts have acknowledged that again
and again in saying that it is the
responsibility of
the legislature to do that
um but they have done it within the
context of the Constitution
which lays out the underlying
constitutional obligation
for a free and appropriate education for
everyone
so that the court is saying to us in the
legislature
do your duty and
um
and I think that is appropriate and I
think it's appropriate for us to
do our duty and to develop the
legislation that could make us all proud
of the public education we have in this
state I do not think that a house
concurrent resolution
accomplishes any of that I think it is
conceivable a constitutional amendment
might be the answer it is conceivable
that additional legislation might be the
answer but a house concurrent resolution
does nothing to achieve our shared goals
and so with respect for the sponsor
um and inviting you to take an
opportunity in your free time to read
the excellent material that former
um
Republican representative Doug Hall
shared with all of us
um I hope you would join with me in
voting itl on this house concurrent
resolution thank you Mr chair
thank you
representative Oregon
oh thank you very much Mr chair of
I just like to add and as our as my
fellow rep from Durham knows because he
was she has served as the chair of the
finance committee we've actually passed
um many large related since the
Claremont decisions about Educational
Funding none of them have been a
entirely satisfactory definitive
advancer but we actually
you know the the law that Educational
Funding is um you know there is law
about Educational Funding sorry advocacy
inform you know the rest of it that
actually you know does it does exist in
law and then a few weeks we'll be um
considering your bill which will
probably make changes of that loss so
like the whole uh
the whole basic premise of the HCR is at
least somewhat factually incorrect in my
opinion
that's about as well I'll allowed to add
to it so like they're gonna I think
Smith said pretty much uh pretty much
said it all in my opinion so
thank you representative Alexander um
thank you Mr chair
um I I do agree with um representative
Smith
um insofar as
um in HCR does not uh provide the
solution to a problem that
um the state uh has to deal in with for
a while
um I believe that you know education for
all is very important whether parental
choice is important you know it's the
public or public charter schools Etc
um but there's other avenues to deal
with this issue including
um addressing you through a cacr
um further actions to the court through
different cases and I just believe that
there's a separation of powers and the
court makes a decision
um you know an HCR to come out that
isn't necessarily move um the move would
be to introduce the cacr so I'll be
voting itl although I do sympathize with
representative Smith
oh I'm sorry uh Mr chair I just didn't
lower my hand
[Music]
for me it wasn't as much about education
as it is about
the
inherent powers of the various bridges
the argument that we have to do a
constitutional amendment on the Supreme
Court
makes decisions that are egregiously
wrong to me it is egregiously
we as an independent branch
that our own responsibilities to read
and
follow the Constitution I believe this
is CR
uel makes that clear
ance and despite the fact that the
Clermont decision was reached out many
years ago
we've never complied with it and I don't
know that we ever will
but beyond that I read dunfile's
testimony
but every word when I get all done I
thought he was for the HCR
because in nowhere in any of what he
wrote
did he he turned in our history with the
state had provided funding
there were so many responsibility other
than to tell the local municipalities
they had to raise some amount of money
and
I don't believe that the court has the
authority
even under the Constitution
to to put the legislature in a position
where it must have been things that it
doesn't matter that that might hurt his
mind
I guess I
scene from somebody that actually was
part of the other political time I can I
can agree with many findings that are in
this bill
you know and getting back to the issue
of whether
you can interpret or cherish
uh at the meeting of the word cherish to
require the state that that requires the
state to make
Financial payments or support and
frankly I always felt from the very
beginning that that was a stretch on the
part of the Court
I think if I even if I agree with all
the findings it's the conclusion that's
really the problem and and that is
that the findings of the Court just
aren't binding at all on the legislature
and that's contrary
to the very way we've operated the
country for 200 years
we from Marbury versus Madison
uh going back to when the founding
fathers
we're we're still alive and accepted
that as the manner in which we would run
our government
and and
to now say we as a legislature just
aren't going to accept that uh I I find
that
anathema I find it uh hard to accept I
just
seems contrary to everything that we
learn in our civics class from the very
first day we went to school so
I I have a hard time
s
okay I guess we're ready to vote
this is on the motion of inexpediate the
legislators
hdr3 H3
representative decline no
um
[Music]
now
representative green no
representative Kelly no
representative trottier
now
representative Marjorie Smith yes
representative
yes
representative Morgan
representative cheers
yes
representative Langley
representative Macbeth yes
representative page yes
representative Simpson
yes
you've adopted the recommendation of
inexperienced legislative be a Minority
Report
foreign
okay
um there are five bills that we haven't
addressed today until 550
five
seventy eight and six thirty those are
the five bills which I think would have
very close votes and I'm sure
representative rice would like to be
here to vote on those bills so
we'll carry those over and I'll make
sure that they're noticed in the
calendar for
is there
any other Mr chair you'll also carry
over
um
540. yep yes they were there were other
bills that we addressed as 540 and there
was one other earlier this morning right
uh is that 216
okay
it was 216. and those those will be
noticed in the calendar as well
uh you know uh there was another build
as well and I it's House Bill 232 and if
you remember in our very first executive
session we voted 10 to 10. and
that not being very satisfying we
recessed the hearing on that
and I will notice that as well so we can
finally address that bill
and uh
440.
if we retain that yes
for red rice yeah we were holding that
over I think yes we're we're holding on
oh that's right of course
so that will be noticed as well in the
calendar
all right
okay uh is there anything else any other
business I'm gonna just ask everybody
who uh has has made the motions and is
going to be doing the committee reports
if they would get their committee
reports to me tomorrow so I can work on
them and get those committee reports out
and that goes for the majority report
I actually have already sent in The
Minority Report I wrote it up at
lunchtime and sent it in so hopefully
and and since we're early getting out
early this afternoon you have time this
all this meeting of the house Judiciary
Committee to a close and we'll adjourn
until we meet on this Friday at nine
o'clock to hear the
last of our bills finally the last of
our bills for uh our house bills I
should say
and we'll see you Friday thank you Mr